hey what's happening Ram Bramblett owes
rambley toes thank y'all for listening
I'm excited about today's episode is
with my good friend comedian former
roommate Darius Kennedy we had a spot in
Logan Square 25 25 North Central Park in
2008 for a few months it now is before
the neighborhood was really pop it
wasn't really much going on it was this
place Heidi biscotti around the corner I
would perform at some times and and I
was about yeah it's a good talk you hear
from somebody that lived with me that I
wasn't related to there's only a handful
of people like that anyways gonna be in
Kent Washington outside Seattle March
23rd at the lemon haze Comedy Festival
we got sleep masks coming you know that
sleep mask merch is coming and we got
t-shirts and and whatnot up on the site
t-shirts some we got to limit it New
Orleans poster from that gig it's a very
beautiful poster and all of that yeah
peace out check it out later
[Music]
we should introduce you got Darius
Kennedy here I'm just kidding yeah
that's me and I'm just happy to be here
but comedian Darius Kennedy who had we
we were roommates one of my own I only
had outside of college I've only had two
roommates and you were wanted of them in
that apartment what year was this 2008
January to June or July 2008 yeah I left
before you left and my buddy Jimbo got a
duplex on Central Park
25 25 weeks a to address because we only
there yeah 25 25 North Central Park okay
in Logan Square free oh that was when it
was a hood it's prehnite like it was
when we had to go to wicker to hang out
it was no like Milwaukee over there was
nothing that was when the opioid crisis
was it was real as [ __ ] we threw that
4/20 party that was a 4/20 party it was
4/20 party yeah and our roommate Jimbo
got mad because somebody stole his Wii
Nintendo Wii yeah but I remember that
party and I had a terrible time because
I divided enough people and so it was
mostly y'all friends and soda
I only a handful of people and then uh
it was uh and I and so it was nobody was
treating me like it was my place so I
felt like a stranger this is my crib
[ __ ] but that sounds fellows
Chang I various your crazy white friends
earn to live
spilling beer all over your couch kick
them out about that whole party was we
do the party we had two kegs we had
bands playing the basement and [ __ ] it
got wildest [ __ ] like we lit up the
whole block so like at the end like
towards the end of the party it was
about 9:00 cop cars yeah chillin on
Central Park outside the crib yeah
because people like young kids came
through and they started fighting and so
the cops showed up and at the end of the
night after we kicked everybody out and
we you know like kind of start [ __ ]
dialing down and [ __ ]
Hannibal's cousin I don't know who it
was but her see yeah yeah he was order
me around like I didn't live in the
place that I threw the party it was like
yeah I'm Hannibal's cousin y'all got any
more beer [ __ ] of you live here I was
like word dawg you making me feel
awkward in the place that I live in and
pay rent for but here's more beer just
me are you okay here's another couple
nuggets from that party there was a
point where I don't know if it's a fight
or scuffle some type of commotion
everybody was kind of unsettled and then
somebody they played Lil Wayne lollipop
yeah and then everybody kind of danced
in ml at the party what else was popping
in Soulja Boy tell them was bad so that
got the party cragit but I remember
lollipop comped everybody down and I do
remember the cops coming into the party
and this is still for 2008 this is my
only time I was happy to see the police
because they were clearing out the part
and I just started pointing my father's
eye he doesn't live you know but who's
that get them at it officer thank you so
much thank you so much of it they don't
live in point everybody out yeah it was
like do you know what that's like it was
like when we had that house party in
Minneapolis oh yeah that was and then
cheese that the do cleanup remember to
shout out the Chiti
that was so oh man we hit up yeah buddy
long shot yeah Chad he's the old buddy
of mine and he's from Chicago lives
Minneapolis now and I just went out I
feel my special there I said let's have
a little you know after-party it's uh
you know invite a few folks over and
then we come from the other club we pull
up yeah it's just like 20 people on the
porch just hanging out just hanging out
waiting already smoking kickin it bro
like like the party already started
without us there they had a spot that
was the spot and they showed up before
y'all yeah yes we showed up and they
were straight kicking it on the stoop
but it was I think it was like a 25
people party crew yeah cuz they all
leave together and never see each other
and it never grew it just stayed like
that it was that was like the ameba I
[Applause]
mean it was just like it wasn't like I
don't think he liked cuz I told I told
Jay I was like let's not get too crazy
you know let's just keep it whatever
yeah and that was what it was but it was
like we didn't know anybody like it was
their own crew so it got a little
awkward so we were just kind of we're
kicking it doing her thing and then you
could take it from there I mean it was
it was well I mean I I don't remember
much it was a lot going on cuz it was
the setup was dope cause it was kind of
it was two apartments or two houses next
to each other so you had this these two
separate spaces with upstairs
so double duplexes yeah so it was cool
yeah I guess it was cool but it is kind
of bad if you got a bunch of strangers
in your place because it's a lot of
little nooks and crannies for my
father's to just kind of I remember that
party and we rode up and it was like to
the point because we didn't we didn't
know like anybody there and then at that
point we're like at first you're like
okay these [ __ ] all know each
other and then you start thinking what
do I have in my bag what do I have my
wrong because there was so many people
just all over the house that I was just
standing in my doorway like I was like I
don't know these [ __ ] said then
I'm done party I'm just like standing in
my doorway like you ain't get towards my
mother I got ya and then your cousin we
were like yo we got to get these people
out here that yes he came in the door
with the four four and just like he was
like everybody out to the Quranic I
almost left I was like yo he cleared
that house out let's go quick the
funniest thing and the weirdest
juxtaposition about that is cheese is
like the sweetest most soft-spoken guy
super chill discerns that he knows that
turn it out like he's big he could he
could be intimidating if he was a new
person to having a quick yeah yeah it's
like cheese man we got to do something
about this he's like we should have just
said something and he just wanted to go
y'all gotta go y'all gotta go can I
bring a more scenario I don't know if
this is safe to say go ahead if not we
just cut
when you had the party and you called me
a couple of like almost a year ago when
you had the party at your spot yeah was
out of my element
y'all go ahead yet so I'm an avid gamer
right and I play video games pretty much
all [ __ ] day if I have nothing to do
so I'm chilling at my crib like me and
my girl like we got to understand and
[ __ ] like I usually game in a day and
then at night we go and hang out and
[ __ ] but like that particular day she
didn't want to come out I stayed at home
I'm chilling at home I get a call from
Hannibal I never get a call from you
ever like it's all strictly text or
email in this particular situation I was
like why is Hannibal calling me and I
pick up the phone he goes hey yo I'm
like what's up man he was like what you
doing tonight Oh Mike I'm just hanging
he was like I'm having a stripper party
tonio it was too early I was trying to
burn that [ __ ] memory out of my brain
yeah HB hits me up he's like yo I'm
having a stripper party I was like oh
[ __ ] and I go what do I bring and then
he goes nothing yeah and I was like okay
um so I picked up two of the cheapest
bottles of champagne I could find as a
gang yeah as a gang came up and went to
the party and [ __ ] and it got to a point
to where I was just trying to talk to
people and I was talking to random
females and [ __ ] on my hey man
what's your name you know she was like
I'm diamond and I was like that's it
and I forgot I was at a stripper party
yeah so I was like oh yes
soon a stripper named diamond not the
person named you know Ashley so whatever
your [ __ ] I'd like to see the first
time you've ever heard of like cher or
Madonna and so alright you know I'm
hanging out merrily was there [ __ ] and
that was like I was barely was there
Tony's recalling everything from a year
and a half ago what else you need to
know dog i you know i'm your your hard
drive over here um but merrily merrily
was there and I was like all right cool
so I was talking to her and I was like
man this is fun as [ __ ] she was like
yeah it's fun and [ __ ] and I was like
I'm not used to strippers or like being
at cool parties so we just started
drinking Jack Daniels in the kitchen and
it got to the point to where I was like
alright I'm at this party I got to
interact with people you know what do I
do
how do you act I think everybody was on
the on the same when I say like what do
we do immigration like nobody knew what
to do I don't want to disrespect it yeah
and that's how I want to at what point
did you give it a party just so I can
imagine I did strippers weren't always
there at one point it was just kind of a
chill oh yeah and it's a hangout and
people playing video games a little bit
I was there like probably a half an hour
before the strip has started okay cuz I
remember because you asked him you were
like bring some weed I'm like cool so I
brought weed and and me one a half oh
yeah just roll it on the table coming
back yeah I came through blessed the
table with my herb and I had actually
hung out with my fiancee she was she
wasn't my fiancee at the time but I was
hanging out with her before like pregame
and this [ __ ] I had a couple whiskey's
and [ __ ] and I was like yeah I'm gonna
go down the street go to Hannibal's
party and [ __ ]
walked in you know with the the
cheap-ass champagne laughing drink some
of that [ __ ] started talking to Marilee
and I was like I don't know what to
[ __ ] do yeah like and then I ended up
just like cheering on strippers like I
was like in the back of the room
clapping going yeah yeah
that's the way you strip yeah I didn't
know what to do you remember I was I was
balling them up hello shooting this one
way to do it I was like McDermott I
think I've done that movie and yeah guys
like I was like I don't know I'm just
trying to lighten the mood and be funny
yeah so I had a good time I can't wait
to hear this [ __ ] story so imma
finish up with this [ __ ] but I had a
good time and it got to the point to
where like I was drinking to feel
comfortable yeah and I was like I'm Way
past my limit bro and I didn't want to
be a burden on the party and be that
awkward ass dude cheering on strippers
[ __ ] drunk as [ __ ] so I slipped out
the back door and then I went to my
girl's place and I was like I told her I
was like yo I went to Hannibal's house
it was a party but it was a stripper
party and I'm sorry mom fiancee goes
baby it's okay no I did like after that
I was like I'm so sorry did I ended up
throwing up all over themselves did you
eat that did you eat the edibles I ate
everything that road you had those you
had those [ __ ] false advertisement as
watermelon slice [ __ ] edibles that
said ten milligrams ain't one of those
[ __ ] and I was high as [ __ ] I
know when she started [ __ ] pulling
away
I started peeking like I was like hi and
then and then there
that random old dude with the black
light he's holding a black light Eagle
[ __ ] the wax is glowing hits her dead
on the vagina I was like [ __ ] a splatter
it and it's glowy I haven't been the
same she was too intense for me oh my
god I have to leave hood because that
[ __ ] was too much for me and then
apologize to my future fiance for having
fun at a party
I would have apologized to was she was
like it's all good baby like that you
have a good time I was like yeah kind of
as the organizer of the event the party
didn't go how I thought yeah my uncle it
wasn't bad but it was just a different
bad it was just a different energy where
we talked about it have a stripper party
but I didn't know that the first couple
strippers will be doing kind of their
expressing the party show yes I just
kind of picture strippers kind of
hanging out ambiance you know what I
mean music that's but I didn't know he
came through and through that tarp down
everybody everybody it is about
everybody in there baby couch he stood
up with his hat on he was like
and I was like even day feels awkward I
have every right to leave right now and
apologize to my future fiance you know
I'm glad we're talking about this
because like I'm hurting myself I'm not
like you and I the only one that's
totally weirded out by this normal shot
feel normal
how am I supposed to act like the
thoughts going through my head was oh my
god that's why I kept throwing the weed
table and it got to a point to where
like my fingers can roll no more weed
yeah and I was like it's time for me to
take my punk ass home oh it was funny
because he's got like art pieces in the
script [ __ ] were pretending
like like they were analyzing the art he
was trying to portray and there's this
old dude just [ __ ] collecting dollars
and old like jewels
it was crazy yeah man I felt so bad as a
partner because I had so much guilty fun
that night I went home and cried to my
fiance and apologized and miss work the
next day like it affected my life it
affected my life as to you know what did
that party it's not if that party wasn't
about being good or bad it was about
changing lives you did that me and
Marilee but we talked about that me and
George George was there we talked about
all talking about it like yeah man I
don't know what to think about that that
[ __ ] was weird as [ __ ] but it wasn't bad
but it wasn't good I was like trying to
keep it calm I ain't good [ __ ] man
last night was dope as [ __ ] he hit me
back like a day after he was like I
didn't go to bed what the [ __ ] up
north or at North the next day without
any sleep and then the fun continued
I was a good oh yeah I was in a
different space December 22nd it was
super [ __ ] fun last minute as [ __ ]
too crazy was life-changing [ __ ] was
real as [ __ ] bro like that was the last
party that I went to before I proposed
to my [ __ ] now fiance I was like I
hit all the numbers I went to all the
crazy parties has super [ __ ] fun now
it's time for me to settle down crazy
party that went to this party I gotta
get married that was not what I was
thinking you know it's always funny when
you had a everybody any event or
especially a party you know everybody
everybody's takeaway is usually
different or you know I just watching
everybody everybody has some different
piece of version of it so it is funny I
enjoyed the [ __ ] man I decided to just
become an honesty that was a fun time
gotta get married now
this is what I realized that I need
commitment in my life real brawls like
be devoted and loyal to me through what
I just went through you like Material
Girl um but yeah I enjoyed the [ __ ] out
of myself that night man that was a lot
of fun it was out of my element you know
I don't even go to strip clubs I'm not
even like like that but I was like I'm
gonna enjoy myself with this cheap
champagne you opened the door I pulled
up with two bottles of Jay Roche yeah
Hannibal's I get your dumb ass in here
and then they had a good time bro it was
perfect the funny thing is that the
alcohol like people didn't bring enough
alcohol so like that alcohol got dranks
so fast like by the time the first
stripper was there this ship was gone
Merilee came through with a
to handle a Jack yes it was gone because
people are like we need to drink through
this [ __ ] it's like that's the only way
we can yeah because people were too high
that was the problem at first everyone
was just high like you just chilling and
then when the strippers [ __ ] and then
and then the tarp and all that like you
got to real high and you see that it's
just too real
yes you just gave me an idea for next
river party try no no we just sober no
no maybe others oh no no I must really
only you know what no what no pregame
either before you walk
are you HOT me get the [ __ ] on with your
cheese at the door yeah yeah
nope [ __ ] at the door who's getting me
beer which Oh dry sober ass tell them I
said what up man I would [ __ ] that
[ __ ] Darius up I've been waiting 15
years to fight him with my hands the
Golden Age of CD DVRs or a CD RS or
whatever they're called cd-rws or
whatever it is the CD rewritable is
where you could basically put music and
then programs on one disc and then like
you know do some [ __ ] with that [ __ ] I
miss that [ __ ] though I'm just burning
CDs and getting excited to listen to
that [ __ ] yeah man I just feel like they
they you know I'm like new technology
but I don't feel like the other [ __ ] has
to be so ruthlessly killed off just
taking out the drives on devices like
nope you don't yeah who's gonna take
that out
down it listen to a circular CD no
that's that's that's true like that's
how it like that's how people felt about
vinyl at first it's like ha man no more
vinyl you know cuz that started coming
around but what's crazy is vinyl is like
Serge recently like vinyl has been
selling like a [ __ ]
yeah there's no people coming back to
tangible music yeah it's it's not only
nostalgic but it's also cool as [ __ ] to
be like I support this artist so much in
that I actually have the [ __ ] the
layout of the whole album the stories
why they wrote these songs like I miss
the days in which you could walk into a
coconuts and buy a CD and you get the
whole booklet liner nothing man like why
they wrote the song the lyrics the song
fighters dedicating it to their sisters
and cousins and [ __ ] you get a book like
this big yeah you remember the 36 track
yes exchangers all the pictures of them
just like hanging out in like a shipyard
looking crazy as [ __ ] I'm like yeah one
of my earliest memories is when my mom
was obsessed with CDs so she she spent
like five hundred dollars to get like a
CD player and it was a wonder CD player
and we used to hang out and the you know
coconuts or whatever music joint that
would sell CDs and sit there and watch
her literally like pick up books of you
know Lisa Stansfield a lot when they
were still in the papers right yeah when
it was a huge yeah yeah that they did
that because people were so used to
buying vinyl so it was like all this
cardboard so there so they did that just
to make just to like compete with the
vinyls like people be weirded out to go
from buying this to buy in to nothis
yeah just like a bookmaker yeah
cardboard so it'd be a big cardboard
rectangular yeah it was an event like
I'm buying like I like this band also
I'm gonna read about why
Addams Family Values has a soundtrack
right now that's right MC Hammer was on
that joint yes he was do yes I remember
yes yes I wanted to jay-z intros I don't
one of his albums he can't it was like
you just got this album from store if
anything like if you anything like me
you probably read in the liner notes
right now what was that was that the
dynasty I think that was the dynasty
album he did that there's an 18 year old
listener right now like I don't know
what the [ __ ] you talking about man
[Music]
[Music]
and reading credits man should be text
it does how accidents happen jay-z that
CD up real quick
jay-z catch use the reckless drive man I
mean cat still reckless drive but that
need driving I remember first time look
ma no hands I know I do that [ __ ]
because I usually smoke her while I'm
driving and I got my hitter box so like
I'll digging my hitter box and then put
my knee on the wheel and [ __ ] and go
back smoke and drive and [ __ ] but I'm
like a pro at that [ __ ] nice yeah man
like I should be the Mario Andretti of
me driving people I text I don't really
text my drivers be changing the music a
lot but I feel like that doesn't as a
way to do it right to do it right when
you get a lot of room in front of you
you know what I mean driving for long
this yeah long distance
yeah you got a hell of space and you and
the left lane and you kind of see what
the general area is then that's a safe
zone you know some stuff but that
traffic no yeah you gotta just be aware
no don't text and drive but if you are
texting and driving
have you'll [ __ ] together ahead on the
goddamn swivel fam like my old football
coach head on a swivel well man Darius
came through Tampa Florida on the road
and [ __ ] got formal shells man yeah we
got four more shows bro and I don't want
to be super sentimental but I appreciate
the invite coming out here gentlemen um
and like I said like last year was crazy
here in my life losing my pops getting
engaged and then to start 2019 doing
what I love with my homies and being
able to share the stage work and having
your confidence and be like yo you know
I want you to come out here and do some
[ __ ] bro means a lot man that's what
something I appreciate that so much
yes sir yes sir all right close it up
and close it up
close it up close up so so so so dope
dope the show is all done demos out all
right you all right
[Music]
[Music]